hey everybody its Jesse and I hope
everyone had a nice weekend and I had I
actually did a lot of coding this
weekend but not for this project for
just a side project for that Udacity
course that I'm taking so I wanted to
start out by just acknowledging Andrew
for his commits so these are all the
people who have submitted pull requests
to this project appreciate everyone
contributing and in this way and I
appreciate everyone contributing in the
live chat as well in the comments and
you all made this project so much better
than it would have been if it were just
me working on it
so anyway Andrew thank you for that and
Andrew also had some great ideas to
improve the the search function for the
resources so I took his ideas and made
an issue now I I fully intend to you
know do this issue myself at some point
but if anybody is interested in this and
would like to contribute to a project
then this one's up for grabs right now
and if you want to learn about you know
debouncing then this might be a good one
too to start out with alright and I
actually had something cool happen right
before the stream started and I had like
I don't know like ten people waiting and
I already had three thumbs up and I
hadn't even started yet that was really
awesome I don't know if anyone was
watching there was one time where I had
I had a thumbs down I don't know like
ten minutes before I even started and I
thought that was hilarious
so now that made up for it cuz I had
three thumbs up before I even started
I appreciate that all right so today I'm
gonna be working on this page so I don't
know if you've seen this before you
might have seen this before cuz I did
this a while ago like weeks ago but I
never really finished it so right now
you can get to it so you can actually go
to the live website and if you just type
in slash news you can get to it if you
click the news button it actually just
takes you to the front page and then
Scrolls you down there's a news anchor
tag to the bottom but this is is
actually live it's just not obvious on
how to get to it but this is going to
end up functioning exactly like a normal
blog would function but they're just
calling it news so it's basically just
gonna display posts and we're gonna have
categories and tags and archive so all
of this was just hard coded in but
what's gonna need to happen is it's
gonna need to pull categories tags and
tags from WordPress and populate these
fields and then we're gonna have to hook
this up so that you know when you click
one of these it actually changes what
appears here the archives will probably
have to do I'm not exactly sure left
you'll have to figure out something
because I can't just I don't think I can
just get an API you'll call back to have
you know archives I suppose I could make
one with a date range that's probably
what's gonna happen I think you can make
a call to WordPress to get posts within
a certain date range that's probably
what's gonna happen I mean right now I
could grab all the posts immediately and
just have filters but eventually if
there's a lot of posts then it wouldn't
make sense to get every post so it's
probably better just to make these be
separate API calls and at some point it
would be good to set
up cashing of API calls because you know
people just clicked around back and
forth it could end up being a lot so I'd
like to have some client-side caching
setup as well but probably not gonna get
that done today today I think we'll just
focus on you know maybe the UI for how
these appear and you know possibly
getting some categories maybe tags
linked up I need to put an image or
something up here as well but I'm not
worried about that we can just throw in
any image for now just to get the idea
of what its gonna look like so that's
pretty much it I have done made some
updates to the new resource section
since the last time not a lot but I've
just kind of moved code out so I'll take
I'll take a second just to show you that
I'd have to check out I just checked out
the master branch so I don't have it
right now so I'll just explain it to you
quickly all I did was just take this new
it's gonna be hard to explain sorry I
might as well just show you so the
branch that I'm working on for the new
UI is just a new resource UI if you
remember I made that last week
all right just to show you so anyway I
did just a bit okay so basically I I
removed a section that was the featured
resources it was a big red section so I
did this I'm not like under percent sure
about this yet but to have this here I
still need to initialize the drop down
here so there will be a drop down there
just move some things around here these
are now their own components in a
separate file so I added in some data
for authors just to give us an idea and
then if there is no author data the
author doesn't show up so I took a lot
of the suggestions that you all had last
week and I've incorporated some of them
already and there are others that I'm
I'm still going to incorporate I didn't
have time before the stream today so
that's it not really major changes and
I'm gonna go back to the master branch
now so that we can get started and let
me check oops
guess I'll have to fix it all right so
let me check the live chat really
quickly just say hi to everyone while
they did a few people here really early
kind of seen if anybody's here everyone
someone here from India awesome welcome
someone from Chile really happy to have
you all watching okay
Helio says there's some info regarding
debounce for the search that's offered
in in lodash so off to check that out
thank you for that I'll check that out
after the after the stream okay
Sebastian asked about the date for the
post yeah that'll be something that'll
need to be added will definitely need
with all the normal things that you
would expect from you know from a blog
will want to put in there with the
exception of probably we won't need
author because they're you know these
are just going to be quick like news
announcements and things so they're not
gonna be exactly like a normal blog post
at least for right now so I think we can
leave out the author but other than that
will want to have the date Nima des what
you - see of course you're doing I'm
doing the react course the one that just
came out so if anybody else is doing the
react course from Udacity then let me
know and so far I'm I'm almost done with
the first project it's it's the book
like a book app if anyone is interested
it's on my my github page it it should
be you know kind of right at the top I
can't remember what I called it but if
you want to check out what I'm doing for
that cool
it is there it's almost finished I
haven't done anything with the UI though
but in terms of functionality pretty
much done I just need to link up react
router so that everything has like the
forward and back functionality works
Oh someone from Norway Hey
all right cool so hey everyone I'm gonna
get started now I'll try to keep an eye
on the chat while I'm going but if you
watch before you know how it is
sometimes you get into the code maybe a
few minutes before I get to check again
but at the end I will do I'll answer
some questions I need to make sure I end
just a heads up I need to end this
before 4:00 because my son has my oldest
son has karate lessons at 5:00 so I'll
probably have to leave around 4 o'clock
so maybe 3:30 I'll start wrapping things
up eastern time this is all Eastern time
so probably do like an hour and a half
of coding and then maybe a half hour of
question-and-answer so I mean that's
that's a decently long stream we'll try
to get as much done as we can so I'm
starting to feel the pressure a bit we
only have till the 20th of this month to
get pretty much everything done that's
in the Trello board for this project
that I have linked up in the description
so like everything in these first three
columns needs to be done and then
potentially anything from this column
that I need also needs to be done so
it's a lot of stuff so I may be I was
hoping I wouldn't have to work extra
this week but I might have to
it's possible there might be some extra
long streams coming they do this week
okay if you have if you have someone
from Germany someone from South Korea
awesome Zanna says ouch that's a lot
chance when do you have the time I'm
just gonna have to work a lot that's
right so I mean my normal work day is
like seven hours of work and I'll just
have to work a lot more than that and
and get it done
it's possible some of the things on that
list could just wait and you know maybe
they're not absolutely necessary so off
I'll go through the list later in the
week and really make sure that
everything on there is absolutely
necessary but otherwise to just I have
to get it I have to get it done and they
I'm gonna move on to another project
after that so in like two weeks we'll be
we'll be working on something different
in you know for the streams so let me
get out of these are the resources oh no
this isn't it so I did switch over I
prepared a little bit today for the
stream I got got this up so as you can
see like like I said this is all
hard-coded so we're gonna have to pull
this in and populate these lists from
from the API this mate instead of being
a list this may end up being a drop-down
because if there's a lot of categories I
don't want a giant list of categories
the tags I might end up making this like
you know like you know you see like the
tag cloud where the tags that are used
most often or bigger I think that would
be kind of cool
so maybe y'all when you get the data
from the API it tells you how many times
the tag has been used so if we link that
piece of data up to the font size then
we should be able to make it so each tag
the tag font size for each tag is based
on the number of times that tag is used
will obviously have you know lower limit
at an upper limit so the font stays
readable at the lower end and it's not
too big on the higher end but I think
that would be a cool feature not
necessary though that might be one of
the things that only happens if we have
time and probably won't get to this
today in terms of you know the dates
also that you know the dates are not
going to be necessary at first anyway
there's just not gonna be enough enough
posts to really warrant really any of
these these things are necessary at
first because there's only gonna be a
few posts but what will work if we can
so first things first let's get some of
those normal blog things in the display
and we'll probably want to take this out
and make it its own component we're
gonna add stuff it's gonna start to get
bigger better just to move it out of
here
so why don't we do that first so I'm
gonna go in case you're not that
familiar with the command line I'm gonna
switch over to the command line and
I'm gonna go type in touch and then
components all right so if you're on the
command line and you want to create a
new file you use the command touch this
is on a Mac and I haven't used a command
line on a PC and so long I can't
remember which commands are the same or
not so possible that the commands I'm
using here won't work but but just in
case that you're kind of new with the
command line this is how you create a
file and I'm gonna make it in the
components folder so right now I'm in
the the just the base folder for this
project I need to go into the components
folder and inside that folder I want to
make a new component called blog j/s so
now if I go back over to the project you
see see if I can zoom I never figured
out there we go
all right I'll zoom in here so you can
see stuff in in my editor at least stuff
in green is are things that have been
added that are new so now we've just
added this blog j/s file all right so it
might seem like why would I want to type
that out when I could have just gone
here and said you know give me a new new
file and I could have just done it there
after a while and you start using the
command line it actually ends up being
faster to just do more through the
command line so if you're new to it
probably nothing is faster than the
command line right now but if you get
used to it it's way faster than any
graphical interface for a lot of things
I even do image editing through the
command line now and I prefer that to
any type of graphical editing so anyway
enough enough of that but I like to go
into some of those little details
occasionally because if people of all
skill levels watching so don't want to
leave people behind with something that
it's simple to me now because I've been
using it for so long but I remember when
I first started like anything on the
command
it's just like a mystery to me and
everybody on YouTube that was just
flying through commands like it just
seems so awesome so we're gonna make
this a component and I'd like to make
this a stateless functional component so
I haven't done this yet on any of the
any of the streams but basically it's
it's a kind of a slightly shorter way to
make a component then what we have been
using and you can't use it all the time
but if you have a component like this
where it's basically not doing much at
all i mean it it's just gonna take some
props and display it and that's about it
nothing else is really gonna be
happening oops I thought I had the news
thing up oh well so but first thing
we're gonna do is import react from let
me double check it from react okay
that's what I thought it was these stuff
in the top I never type out I'm always
just copy and pasting it so I have to
double check what I'm using it so now
we're gonna say Const and we're gonna
call this blog equals and let me I'm
actually gonna double check I'm gonna
bring up on my other screen my project
do I have it here there we go this is
from my project for the Udacity course
I'm gonna put on the other screen so
this is where I learned this stuff from
the course so it's I'm trying to use
what I'm learning immediately so don't
forget it so I'm gonna bring it up on
the screen so I get all the syntax right
because I don't want to waste your time
with me messing up the syntax trying to
seem like I know this stuff by heart
when I really don't alright so basically
this is it we just have to export
and that's it that's all we need so let
me compare this to another kind of
similar component so let's check out
like this resource card so basically
doing the same thing there they're just
taking in some props and displaying it
now of course the resource cards has a
bit more here but look at what we have
so the import is slightly different
because we're important component but up
here you know we believe make a class
right and then we have this render
function and then we have to say with
the return within there okay and then we
export so basically we're getting rid of
the render and the return this is
slightly shorter this line is get rid of
a few brackets and then we end up having
something that's a lot a lot cleaner
looking so not really like a really huge
difference but it looks a bit nicer also
you all show you in a second the way we
call on these props is slightly
different than what we do so we'll say
like this props you don't need this
anymore within here you can just say
props so that's the only that's really
the only big difference in terms of what
you're going to do within within here
all right so let's bring this I lost my
news page here it is so let's bring the
news here we go
that's actually weird this is I
highlighted this div and it's giving me
it's I think I messed that up and never
knew about it so I did i made this weeks
ago but it seems like I need to have
another another div inside of here right
oh I know what happened
okay this still works actually I
remember thinking the same thing now
weeks ago so I'm just closing this div
since it's I'm just gonna make a div
here and then that way it won't keep
tricking my editor and in a week I won't
forget again and have it confuse me okay
so let's just copy this and I can get
rid of get rid of it because we're gonna
pull it in as a component and we need to
slug title when you make sure we pull in
the same props that it needs so we need
to get the slug we need to pull in a
title we need the content also we're
gonna need to pull in the date and
obviously I don't remember what the date
format is and so we'll probably have to
do something with the format of the date
to make it more presentable but for now
it was a day we need the slug title and
content alright so here we're going to
bring in his component blog and then
we're gonna pass in the props that we
had before to let me since we're gonna
be working on both of these
let's move this blog component over here
so we can see them side by side let me
know if this font is too small
I'll make sure I'll check back in like
30 seconds in the live chat
if it's too small for you I can
definitely I can make it bigger it's
it's comfortable right now for me but if
it's too small for you I can definitely
make it bigger so let's bring in slug
slug and we need a title title rendered
oops I got the equal sign and if you're
not familiar with react and a lot of
this is over your head I apologize in
previous videos I have taken a little
bit more time to explain this so if you
if you want to watch me explain it you
can kind of check out some of the titles
of the videos and titles that would talk
about specifically about react
components will probably have the best
explanation but I don't really think
that my videos are the best to get kind
of a tutorial so you might want to you
know check out the docs and for react or
check out some other videos or courses
on react to get a better idea of what's
kind of going on here I'll do my best to
explain it so right now we are passing
in what are called props so that this
component here can use all the data that
we're pulling in in this component this
we're going to pass on that data through
props it's the last one we need is
content right yeah
we always want to make sure we close it
so all the HTML like tags in react when
you're using JSX
have to be closed you'll get an error
otherwise so make sure you you're
closing everything and that looks good
we we do need to make sure that we're
importing this because right now this
component will have no idea what we're
talking about because we haven't
imported it so let's go up here and
we're gonna import actually I'm just
gonna copy this paste it and change this
to the log oops so now it's importing
the component blog from the folder
components blog you don't have to put
the dot je s at the end it knows that
all these are going to be JavaScript
files so now what should happen is when
I save this I'll actually want em so we
didn't change anything over here but
when I change this to reflect these
names of these props it should
everything should look exactly the same
as it did before so I just need to to
change this and instead of post it's
gonna be props so props slug and
and then also we don't need rendered
right since we're bringing in
we're already bringing in the rendered
version of this content and this this is
not like some special command this is
just the way the JSON file is formatted
that comes from WordPress okay so now
I'll save this file and I'll save this
file and let's check out and see what
the site looks like yay it still looks
the same
so I'll refresh just to be sure usually
we get a you know an instant refresh
actually good thing I refreshed it looks
like my dev server is up here just click
my dev server has quit working once
again
hmm I is not defined uh-oh looks like I
forgot something
oh the key okay so I was bringing in a
key and it was just an iterator so I
need to pass that in I forgot about that
so let's pass in the key and this will
be I and then here it should work we'll
just need to put it in drops dot I so in
react if you're going to be you know
iterating over components and rendering
the same component over and over again
each one has to have a unique key it
doesn't have to be unique to your whole
react application but has to be unique
among those sibling components so in
this case you know it's just the the
iterator so it's just gonna be like 0 1
2 3 4 all right but we could each each
of these posts will have their own ID
that's been given to it from WordPress
so we could use that if we needed to but
we don't really need to need that so
since we wouldn't I would normally pull
in the wordpress ID of something if i
was only gonna use it for the key but if
i needed it for something else then i
probably just use it for the key - all
right so now it works so now we can see
we have this and just to kind of show
you in dev tools react so if you are
doing anything with react I highly
recommend getting the react extension
for dev tools I have no idea how I
initially got this it's been too long so
I can't remember but I'm sure I know it
wasn't difficult to load up on here so
let's see news first here we go so we
have blog just to show you the name
of the component now as it is using the
blog component and you can see we have
these props are being passed so this is
the content being passed we have this
love the title so it's working exactly
how we wanted to I'm gonna check the
live chat since it's been quite a while
since I checked it Wow everyone in the
live chat has been busy this is this
huge since there's so much activity the
live chat I'll say it right now if you
ask a question early on and I don't get
to it there's a chance that I might not
ever see it because when the chat gets
really big the stuff that the comments
that came earliest I can't read them
anymore they're just gone
so if I do miss your question and you
stick around for the Q&A at the end you
can just ask it again or you can put it
in the comments to this video or you can
message me on Twitter and I'll answer it
I'll answer it then okay so I scrolled
back up to the last place I looked
oh yes people from Austria Romania
Albania awesome
Venezuela that's awesome I love hearing
where where you all are from I think
it's a really fun that it's really fun
that so many people from all over the
world in different time zones are all
coming together and you know there's
just so much nice interaction the live
chat you all helped me out a lot it's
just really cool
oh there is some talk in the live chat
about the the link to my Udacity project
yeah and I didn't even think about it
but yeah so this project this react CI
is underneath FUS marcom so it's
Franciscan University of student ville
marketing department my page let me go
to my profile what's mine mine is Jessie
our Weigel so what I'm talking about is
this one this my read starter project so
sorry about that I totally forgot that I
had had the other project under a
different no what do they call one I
can't remember organization is how they
call it an organization account anyway
yes I haven't even changed the readme or
anything yet I just I just was like
trying to focus and work through and get
all the functionality down before I mess
with anything else because it's so easy
to get caught up in the the UI and you
know trying to make the reaming
everything that I thought this is gonna
take me forever I just want to make sure
I get it done alright okay cool and
Sebastian had already put in the live
chat the the link that I just showed you
so I should have just scrolled down a
bit as Anna said could you sometimes
just film your editor while you code
without being distracted by talking to
us I would look at that I mean if you
don't have the time for talking okay
I never thought about doing that I
always figured that would be boring but
yeah I love to think about that so yeah
let me know what you all think the
suggestion was I made I don't have time
and it's true like I don't have I
couldn't
do this all day because it does take
extra time to do the talking and things
I think it's it's really valuable for me
because I get so many great ideas but it
does it slows things down a bit so
there's a lot of things that need done
that I know how to do it it just it
needs to get done and they're not really
you know fun to watch I would I would
say so I don't record them but maybe if
you all would be interested in seeing
some recordings which are basically me
just working not talking I might be
interested in that I don't know that I
would take up the free code camp channel
with all that all day in case you know
occasionally there are some I know
Quincy does some live interview
sometimes so I wouldn't want to be a you
know on all the time so I'd either do it
either like on my channel my youtube
channel or maybe I'd get like a twitch
channel or something to do that sort of
thing but I'm I'm open for that if you
alright I get I would kind of feel bad
not talking to anybody but I guess if
you're interested I would I'd be fine
with that
vim Rossi asks is there any difference
in commands for Ubuntu or Mac I don't
really I've never come across any
difference not not to say that there
aren't any differences maybe there are I
but I have personally never seen any
difference between Mac and Linux
commands
okay wrote Rohan is getting deep on me
here and say saying you are using a PC
you aren't using Windows says even
modern Mac's our pcs technically
technically all Macs are IBM
pc-compatible so yes so good distinction
roll on so on Windows the commands are
different yeah let's not vim Brasi says
don't start Mac versus windows here yeah
I didn't mean to start I mean I don't
care if in the live chat you have
discussions about you know whatever as
long as it's you know not not being mean
to anybody I guess but yeah I don't mean
to argue I own several PCs and a Mac and
I have a Chromebook and I run I don't
have a Linux you know computer that I
use but I use Linux on my servers so so
I can see the benefits and all of them
they all have good things about them
although anymore the only thing that I
use Windows for really is for gaming and
I don't really have that much time for
gaming now at all I'd probably been
months since I've played a computer game
you know on a Windows computer
okay Andrew R asks about the Udacity
course link yeah I guess I can post it
do you mean specify first do you mean
the link to like sign up and register
for the course or are you talking about
the link to my project for the course if
it's the link to my project it already
has been put in the chat by Sebastian a
little bit higher up in the chat if it's
the link to the Udacity course I could
give you a link but I think they're
really pushing the course a lot right
now so I think the homepage for Udacity
would you just be Udacity calm I'm
pretty sure that they have it on the
homepage at least they did at one point
I know there's discussion there's always
a discussion about the editor always us
I wonder how long you can keep it going
that like there's gonna be discussing
about the editor and every single every
single time I stream which is cool I'm
not gonna get into the discussion I just
noted somebody did ask about whether it
was still slow i I think the Adam editor
to me at least to seem like it has
gotten faster than it was it's still not
as fast like Visual Studio code seems
faster to me it's possible that's just
because I have a lot more plugin it's
going for Adam but in general vs code
seems faster but Adam seems way faster
than it did when I first got it which
was a few years ago I think I started
using Adam like when it when it first
came out really close to it so it was
quite slow at one time
adhi I'm not sure how to pronounce it's
a Adi says am I the only new beer you're
not the only new beer I - I'm a new
Santa says we're all react noobs that's
why we're here some are more advanced
yeah ok I'll I'll make sure I'd try to
do a better job of explaining things for
those who are not familiar with react
and it looks like there's some good
explanation going on in a live chat as
well so thank you all for for taking the
time to explain that to the people who
aren't familiar with it oh cool Zanna it
said she finished the code academy code
academy react course react 1 awesome I
went through those when they first came
out I don't know if they have more I
want to check again to see if they've
added on to the course or anything if
there's more to do but I remember it
being pretty helpful unfortunately after
I took that course I didn't have a
project that I was doing in react so I
forgot most of what I had learned in
that course but I think it all kind of
sticks around in long-term memory so
it's the next time I tried to learn it I
get caught on quicker ok
almost almost through with the with the
live chat I got to try to look back more
frequently so I don't have these giant
periods where I'm taking a break from
coding I think it just might be better
for those of you watching it's possible
there are some people that don't really
care about the latch and just want to
see the code
Mohammed Khan ass is it worth doing the
Codecademy course for me I think it was
worth it it's somewhat depends on how
advanced you are with react and how you
like to learn best I found it to be I
find most of the codecademy things to be
like a lot of like really I can holding
step by step and I often don't know
enough at the end to really do a project
on my own but it helps me to get that
little bit of confidence and knowledge
of things without having to commit to
like setting up my own development
environment for it and everything so I
think it's worthwhile it might slightly
be a waste of time if you're you know
more than just the beginner at react you
may pick up a few things but it might
not really be worth it if you already
know a bit so but I I thought when I did
it that it was worthwhile but I was
really really new at react to the point
where like I I knew you know almost
nothing I had just seen some people use
it at a conference and knew enough to
knew that I wanted to know more but that
was it
okay all right looks like Jax's doesn't
mind listening to the the to the chat me
revisiting the chat so okay cool
alright she also have some people
talking about the best training courses
for react so someone mentioned free
cocaine yeah free code camp is good to
learn your basic JavaScript I haven't
checked out the new free code camp so
there's a beta version of free code camp
that I think does go and more it does a
lot more with react I haven't looked at
the beta version for a really long time
like months and months so I don't know I
can't speak personally about what it's
what it's like but I'm pretty sure it
has some stuff for reacting you can
check out the beta stuff now so if you
like free code camp you can check out
the react stuff from free code camp
alright so let me go back now I've
gotten through a lot of the live chat I
skipped over some stuff I'll come back
later on and really look through it but
I think I got the important questions
when I go back to the live chat really
what I want to do is make sure anybody
especially who's new that I make sure I
address the questions because I know you
know those of you who watch for a long
time I'm sure you're okay if I miss
something at some point and but I don't
want new people to feel ignored
especially if they're know not only new
to this channel but you know they're
also new to coding so I want to make
sure that everybody's everybody is
addressed you know at least at some
point especially if I see something like
a new person that I haven't haven't seen
before in the live chat so hey or
somebody joining in IT engineer join in
so hey thanks for watching
breakpoint recommends the official react
tutorial so yeah check that out I can't
believe I forgot to mention that yeah
the react like the react.js website has
a tutorial to go through so that would
also be cool dealing for that is you you
do set up your development environment
on your own computer from there so if
you're not comfortable with that part of
it then maybe you'd want to do something
that's more in browser like Codecademy
free code camp stuff browser-based first
to get you comfortable but if you're
already comfortable setting up a dev
environment then yeah the react course
the react to toriel is is great ok one
more from the live set before we get
started so vim Rossi says I'm 30 years
old
Nubian web development D recruiters have
age bias when hiring I don't know that I
actually I'm not sure that I can answer
that
you know accurately from what I have
heard there's a lot of people in the
free code camp forum and also on medium
the do blog posts and talk about their
experience getting hired and almost
everybody that I read about getting
hired is older than 30
it's just especially lately it seems
like everyone that's writing about being
able to get a job is older than 30 so it
seems like maybe there's maybe there's
not they're getting a job but that's
entirely you know anecdotal I don't have
any data to back up anything like that
but it looks like I'm 31 right now I got
hired something I was like 28 or 29 when
I got hired so not you know right around
30 so at least for me I was able to get
hired and I hope that there's not a lot
of age bias because if I want to if I
ever want to switch and get a job
somewhere else I'm definitely gonna be
older then
am now so I'll probably you know be
older than 30 for sure so anyway I don't
really know maybe if someone else has
some some better insight into the world
of recruiters you could you know kind of
contribute there in the live chat all
right so let's let's go back actually
just reminded me my my dad told me
yesterday that he's gonna retire in
September the end of September
I think he's 57 now and I told him I was
asking him what he's gonna do any
retires and I said you wanna learn how
to be a developer I said I could teach
you how to do stuff and so he said his
you know he's 57 and he's gonna I don't
think he's gonna really learn how to be
a developer but I'll try I'll try to see
if you know even if he doesn't want to
get a job as a developer he'd be cool to
be able to talk about the stuff with my
dad but I really think he could I told
him he'd get a lot of publicity if he
published his journey to becoming a
developer after a retiring I think that
would be a cool story I told him I tell
everybody on Twitter about it if he did
do it but all right
okay I had a reminder for a meeting so
normally on Mondays I have this meeting
at 3:00 p.m. but today my department
head came in and asked for the data that
I was supposed to give in the meeting
and I had already put it into a
spreadsheet and it was already raised
she said okay you don't have to come to
the meeting which is awesome because I
need all the time I can get for this
project and that means I get to do a
longer stream which which is really
great I was actually kind of in a kind
of a down mood all day until I started
the stream so thank you everyone for
helping improve my my mood just had some
some bad stuff happen in my in my family
this weekend so I was just kind of
about that but let's get back to this
let's go let's put in a date so let's
see what format we're gonna get when we
try to pull this date in and we'll try
to reformat it in a way that's a little
bit easier to read if we need to if I
want to switch this order right now cuz
it'll keep bothering me so I'd like to
keep the code in the middle so I can
just quickly kind of move move the
screens
okay so we're gonna be working first we
need to pull in the dates
okay so right now we are just getting
posts and I'm pulling in all everything
so we should be able to bring in the
date I'm gonna check the kind of the raw
API data and so we can check out what we
have to work with and I'll bring it over
here on this screen so y'all can see it
as well all right so this is all the
data that we have to work with right now
when we get we pull in posts so it looks
like we have so we have a date and this
is the date format so we definitely need
to change this format
quickly I'm just gonna kind of look
through and see if there's any other
data that we probably should be putting
in there
Oh actually I'm wondering if I should
pull in any any images into this view I
don't think I'm going to right now just
because I have such a short amount of
time to get this all done I I think I
kind of like well I mean the way it
looks right now listen great but I can
see what it will end up looking like
kind of in my mind and I think I like it
without the images we'll see if I need
to put in the images later on I will
when for certainly when people click to
go and you know when a user clicks and
goes into the main you know single post
page and images can be there but on this
page I think it might be nice to not
have them oh we are gonna need the
categories yeah we need to bring in
categories because we want to set up
some filters before when people click on
these different categories so normally
in a blog setup like if this were just a
wordpress blog you'd click on a category
and there'd actually be an entire page
for those categories I don't think
that's necessary for this that does give
the advantage of having an actual link
someone could go to but it's it's really
rare that you could share a link to a
category page on a blog so I think I
mean you can let me know I just I never
bookmark or share links to category
pages on blogs so maybe maybe people do
and I'm just not aware of it I just
glanced back at the latest comment from
Elaine I'm sorry I really didn't feel
bad if I mess up your name
it's al AI n says I have no idea that
you can react in WordPress so yes I mean
technically it's not a wordpress site
I'm just pulling in data from a
wordpress site that's on a different
server but you could actually use react
like within a wordpress theme I've never
done it I've seen I've seen some stuff
on github of people doing it and I'm
pretty sure they've done it successfully
but I've never tried to do it I always
just thought you know if I'm gonna use
react I'm gonna do you know an entirely
separate react site but maybe there are
some advantages to doing it you know
more like the traditional WordPress
theme route I'm just not really aware of
them okay we need to make sure we we
pull an announcement I don't think we're
going to need to mess with us right now
so basically the there are two types
they're going to be news and there's
gonna be announcements I'm not entirely
sure what the difference is between news
and announcements it doesn't really
matter for what I'm doing though because
I'm not gonna be entering in content but
it's possible that we could do we would
want to put tabs for news and
announcement but I don't think so I
think it'd be fine to just put things
you know right just right in order on
the home page they will be separated
from news and announcements so I'm not
I'm not too worried about it and I'm not
sure that a user coming to the site
would know all right well what's the
news with falls under news what falls
under announcements I don't know that it
would actually be useful to anyone to be
able to filter by news and announcements
these categories are gonna be better and
then we will probably put in a search
function somewhere and that will be more
okay sorry I'm just doing a lot of
thinking out loud here and not a lot of
coding but I guess it's better to do
this first than to have to code
everything over and over again because
of changing my mind halfway through okay
so I think we're we're good let's pull
in the date we'll just stick is one step
at a time I feel like I just planned out
everything for this page all at once and
we haven't gotten much done so let's
pull in the date first and then let's
convert this date this was actually be
cool to do because dates always drive me
crazy
I've successfully worked with them and
displayed them before but I always
forget how I did it so I'll have to look
up some previous projects because I'm
pretty sure on a previous site I took a
date in that exact same format from
WordPress and then displayed it in a
more user friendly way I think I did off
the double check all right so let's pull
in first we're gonna pass in the date
like if you remember we're getting the
data from WordPress the WordPress API
here and the news component and this
news component is our entire news page
and then we're grabbing the data here
and then we're passing that data to our
blog component and we're passing it as a
prop or as you know multiple props so
let's go date and we're gonna say post
date so now we're gonna pass that in
will now have access to date here within
our blog component so we're gonna put
the date let me look quickly maybe the
date could go right underneath the title
we'll see how that looks really I mean
it's gonna go either above the time
below the title probably the best places
to put it
so we'll try below first here's our
title it's an h2 and it is it's wrapped
in a link tag let's make this we just
put into this a span and we're
definitely gonna style it so that it's
it shows up but for now we'll just put
it in here as from date
okay so this is just the test to make
sure we've imported it properly it's
obviously gonna look there you go like
this alright so first things first let's
get this reformat it we are also going
to want to move it up a bit I don't mind
the size it's kind of small but I'm fine
with that because I don't really want
the date to be the focus so I'd like it
to be smaller than the title and the
excerpt but I would like to move it up
so that it sits right under here so
we'll probably a lot of this this
padding is more this is probably because
of the H text we'll probably need to set
some styles on this H tag to bring this
up but first let's get this date going
so first thing I'm going to do is check
out a project where I use this
previously actually I can go here it's
already open I did a project this is a
private repository right now so
unfortunately you won't be able to check
it out it's got to be private because
the entire website is private well I
thought it was I thought I had worked on
it
there is so actually this is an
interesting phrase I could show this
project more maybe with I redo it one
day I'll convert it to react but this is
the same concept I'm pulling data from
the WordPress API but instead of doing
it with react
I made the entire UI and all the
interactions and everything with jQuery
so I really wish I could show you just
like how insane the code is even the
routing so like the URLs all work each
post has its own URL every time you do a
search it has its own URL every category
everything so it's insane and the readme
is somewhat unrelated because once I set
it to private
I just didn't care about the readme
anymore but anyway let's let me go
yeah I think let me move this over
quickly
I don't think I have anything in this
code that I shouldn't show but just in
case okay I do have some stuff about the
date here no no but I don't think I
actually displayed to the user so I
thought I did I thought this is going to
be easy and I could just copy and paste
some code from a previous site but I
don't think it's gonna be that easy
it was worth a shot though oh wait a
second no I did display it awesome I
just have to find where I display it
alright let me bring this back over just
to show you a bit of the the craziness
of this code I don't recommend doing
this ever because as you'll see now like
trying to go back through this code and
figure out what is going on even though
I made it all it's just crazy
so you see this is just like a really
really long file of JavaScript so like
if you ever hear people like warn you
which I always heard the warnings like
you know you don't want to do this and
all jQuery you end up with spaghetti
code it'll be unmaintainable like I
always heard the warnings but I never
really saw it like but it does really
happen all right so let me I need to
find my temp so at some point I have
like templates in here so I didn't use a
templating library I just use template
literals like the es6 template literals
to make templates do you see this this
whole thing is using I'm pretty sure I
use like too here we go here's one part
of the template so I was using source
set to serve like different size images
but I had to first check to make sure
that that post actually had an image of
that size before I did anything so I end
up with lots of stuff like this here we
go I know somewhere in here I have the
dates
you should be alright so I have the
category tags and
now I can't find it
maybe it's down here so I let me know if
this is really boring you going through
this this really kind of badly written
code
I'll check the live chat in a second and
if if you all don't want to see it I'll
quit but um I think I'm really close to
finding the point at which I have the
date this day any day for this to be
done okay I got some date stuff going on
yes here it is
alright so we're showing a title and
then this dates okay
all right cool this is gonna be very
useful all right so here's what I did so
I took the date and I made it I set it
to a variable and I've no idea why you
let there that definitely could have
been cost see you can kind of see like
my progression of this was all build
this was built less than a year ago so
right around this time last year is when
I started to build this so this has been
less than a year since I've come from
jQuery spaghetti code and kind of using
es6 but somewhat improperly
to now where I'm at now which I think I
still have a lot to learn and I still
consider myself kind of a newbie in a
lot of areas but you definitely see the
progress that's always cool if you ever
get down on your coding progress just
look at something you did you know like
a year before or you know even like six
months before and then you'll you'll see
how far you've come and you'll feel you
feel a lot better about your your
progress okay so basically what we need
to do is take that date we're going to
set it all right to a JavaScript date
object I think that's how you would you
would call it then we're gonna take that
and we're just gonna break it out so
that I'm gonna take this oh I named it
this date right so that that new date
that will save as a variable will pull
the month out and then the months are
actually zero indexed in javascript
dates so we do have to add one to the
month to get it to display properly then
we'll get the the date which would be
like the day of the month that's not
zero indexed so we can display it
normally this is crazy I think
JavaScript dates are like the weirdest
thing for me that you have some stuff
seer index some stuffs not so there's a
lot of areas that could trip you up and
you wouldn't really know unless you
and to read something about it or like
like me like I've tried to do it and
couldn't figure out why the date was
always one month different than it
should have been it's just it took me a
lot to figure that out and then finally
we get the full year so the format is
just month / day / year that's a decent
format I think I can keep it like that I
think I will keep it like that and then
that'll be the simplest for me yeah
so let me I'm gonna put throw this over
on my other screen so I can refer to it
let's try to do the same thing but in a
nicer way with no jQuery I don't think I
actually used any jQuery in that example
I just showed you so we can probably use
most of it pretty much exactly as is so
let's
trying to think of whether I want to
turn that
I think I want to pass it pass the date
object in and I think we can do this I
think this will be okay so here instead
of on post date I want to put it pass in
new date and then the post date right
this will save us from having to create
a separate variable that'll be the date
like like I did in the the other example
and we'll just pass that and we won't
have to create another variable and then
on the other side we can just do
whatever we want what we need to with it
as a date object so hopefully it'll work
and so then over here where we have date
props date we it's still called the same
thing it's still going to be prop state
but instead we're gonna do first we're
gonna say this actually I think I can
copy this whole thing the strattice if I
copy this entire thing and I actually
put it in a template literal and I move
all that this date stuff and turn it
into props date
then that should work let's check it out
did I move it away I think I must yell
yeah I've moved it on my other screen
obviously but it worked so check it out
we have the date the word correctly
alright alright I'm gonna check back in
with the live chat now that I've
succeeded at something hey check the
time - okay so probably about like 20
more minutes of doing code and then I'll
do some question and answer I'm gonna
try to find out where I left off in the
live chat okay I think I found it
all right awesome so
adhi says please tell me how to use a
java console as the developer tool yes
so the JavaScript console
oh also from Nepal awesome that's
awesome thanks for watching what's the
what's the time in Nepal it should be
around what like 1:00 a.m. over there
something like that
if so awesome thanks for watching that
late if someone from Guatemala Poland
alright yeah my um I have on my wife's
side of the family relatives they came
from Poland and then on my my one of my
grandmother's her parents were were from
Poland so really cool I'd like to visit
there one day I mean that would be fun
coming from Oregon from Sarajevo awesome
okay let me get to here let me answer
your question I was distracted by all
the the places everywhere how much I
love learning more about all these
places around the world but I actually
have never been outside my own country
so I mean I'm from the United States
says it's quite a large country so I
have been to a lot of places within this
country but I've never been outside so
that way I would really love to one day
I'd love to visit everywhere but maybe
maybe it'll happen one day I think he'd
be really cool to go to a like a
JavaScript conference in another country
that would be fun maybe like to speak at
a conference or something so that gets I
get to see the other country and meet
all kind of people there and then also
like code I would that would be cool so
let's let me show you how to use dev
tools
so hopefully hopefully you're still
watching because I think the question
was asked quite a while ago like 45
minutes ago super easy to use dev tools
if you're using Chrome the Chrome
browser you just right-click go down to
inspect and you click inspect that
brings it up once you're in here the
first screen you'll see is this which is
basically your Dom so it's all your
elements on the page if you click on one
of the elements you'll have this
depending on your screen width it might
be configured differently but if you
click on one of the elements it'll show
you all the Styles associated with it
it'll tell you what style sheet that
it's from and even what line on that
style sheet that these you know see bits
of CSS are located in so it's really
cool if you don't want to go through it
this way you can go this is often
helpful for me they just kind of stack
them all up here so it's easier to read
and then if you click on one then you
can see exactly where it came from you
also have you know this thing down here
is kind of handy you can switch around
and see this is your console so you can
see warnings and things down here you
can even you see a bigger version here
if you click this tab and then you can
even put things down here so I could do
like some JavaScript cause test equals
five right and now I can go test and
it's five right so I've just done
JavaScript and she could write
JavaScript in this console and just to
test things out so it's really cool
there's so many things it would I mean I
could do like a month worth of live
streams just going over dev tools
there's so much stuff in here check out
your network requests there's so much
stuff but anyway that's like the basic I
would say 90% of what I use is all just
in this screen right here so anyway hope
that was helpful I know it was I mean
it's just a few minutes but maybe
that'll be good to get you started
okay regarding the the question from a
long time ago about Zanna had about
maybe I could just do some videos where
I don't talk and I just code I think she
just doesn't like to hear me I'm just
joking I don't see no she's asking
because basically you like I know
obviously can't talk in code all day
like it was it's it's a little bit
slower to talk when I code and then I
would probably lose my voice to be
honest with you if I if I try to talk
all day in code but so maybe you all
would be able to see more of what I do
and I just wouldn't worry about talking
I would just show my screen so I asked
for some feedback from you all about
that
Rohan said maybe I could just post a
recording instead of a live stream
that's definitely a possibility as well
I said maybe I could do it on Twitch I
just I don't want to take up the free
code camp YouTube channel for like all
day for a really long time in case
someone else like Quincy wants to do a
live stream of an interview or something
Monica says twitch would be cool
addy says no please do it on YouTube I
don't use to it yeah that's I would have
to learn how everything works with
twitch so maybe it would be better I
have my own channel on YouTube and I
hadn't planned on doing live streams on
that channel but I could yeah so maybe
maybe I'll just do it on that channel
okay sign up so then was talking about a
sign-up link I think he needs to sign up
link for the Udacity course so I will
I'll put that in the stream let me look
that up on my other screen here let's
see oh yeah yeah okay so Sebastian did
mention the courses it's five hundred US
dollars and I don't know so I'm not sure
if the price is different depending on
the currency or how they are doing that
but it's definitely it's not free I
forgot to mention that it's actually
yeah it is so I'm gonna put it in the
debt right now but it actually is right
on the home page it's the very first
thing on the home page is a big button
that says enroll now to become a react
developer so yeah this is actually the
first course I've paid for to learn
anything
coding related in a really really long
time I did like a 30 dollar course I
think from udemy a few years ago but
that's the extent of what I've paid
Prince Prince Ali Khan ass how's the
Udacity course so far I really like it
I'm learning a lot I'm incorporating
what I've learned so far into my
projects already so that's really cool
it's been cool for me it consists the
course the the Nanosuit see reacts
nanodegree so the nanodegree program
consists of three courses so one course
you learn like the basics of react I
forget what the second course focuses on
I think it's like Redux and and things
like that and then the third course is
react native which lets you build like
apps like mobile apps with react so so
far I've gone through all the course
material for a course one and I'm almost
finished with the final project for
course one as well so maybe if you're
interested I can give you all updates of
how the course is going and then if it
ends up being good then maybe you want
to pay for it but then otherwise you
don't you don't have to spend your own
money to before you know whether it's
good or not I'll let you know but I've
been I've been happy with it so far
Mohammed Khan says free code can't
taught me all the JSI know the outer
section was the best well that's really
that's kind of cool
thanks for saying that okay actually I
think I scrolled up a bit too far I must
have just passed over some stuff and
that's why I thought that I didn't get
to that section before but this is no
problem I'm glad I saw some of the
comments that I had missed oh cool
Zanna says she read about a guy on
medium that was like 57 or 59 and was
becoming a dev so that's really cool
you been rusty says hats off to your
comment Jesse but I can't remember what
I said that would that would deserve a
hats off so I wish I would've read that
closer to when I said it
Janice says sorry Jesse I'm not sure
what you were apologizing for I don't
think you did anything that you'd have
to apologize for
yeah there we go okay it says Santa said
I should have Adam embedded on my screen
or a bot that talks about that would
actually be cool I don't know how to do
BOTS in the YouTube live chat but that
would be cool
basically I always get asked like
usually multiple times in the live chat
what what editor I'm using so it's kind
of like a running joke that there will
always be a discussion of my code editor
I don't mind it I think it's really fun
to see how many times I get asked head
ok I didn't see Zanna said she have to
get had to go and I missed it so she
probably can't hear this but thanks
thanks for watching hopefully you can
join us again tomorrow maybe she'll
watch the recording and and hear that
okay Manish is saying the the browsers
dark github is dark yeah so uh yet I'm
using a Chrome extension called
tampermonkey and then I load it into
tampermonkey some code that's called I
think it's called github dark anyway
it's so it lets you change the the
colors of github so you can go in and I
think I have I thought it ended up
giving me like an extra there we go it
gives you an extra setting panel in here
so you can change I haven't even looked
at any of these other themes maybe I
should check out these other themes at
some point I won't mess with it now cuz
I'll end up taking a lot of time just
looking through that but yeah so
tampermonkey is so to get the github
dark script so you'd have to install
tampermonkey first and then find the
github dark script and then use that
with tampermonkey but it's really cool I
kind of like it
okay let's do yeah let's just do a bit
more with the code and then I've done a
pretty good job of keeping up with a
live chat so it might not take that long
to go through all the questions but if
you if you have any questions for me
then
go ahead and put them in a live chat now
and I'll get to them in a few minutes
and we'll just do some some Q&A at the
end here but for now let's see what we
want to want to do so we have this let's
let's do some some basic CSS stuff and
that'll be cool because that way if
anybody in here is not great with react
yet then maybe you're you're better with
your CSS skills so it'll be easier to
understand so we're just gonna make this
date you know kind of sit just right up
here a bit and then let's change the
color here for our posts for post titles
I might drop this down to an h3 I think
it's in h2 right now so let's just try
to do those three things at least and
then they will do some some QA so first
thing is let's let's inspect this and
see whether it's a margin or padding
that we're dealing with so let me shrink
this up so I can see so it looks like
it's a margin so we have a margin of 30
yet and let me see I don't need this
down here something to get rid of this
okay I think if we set the margin oh the
bottom margin is only 24 I think if we
set this bottom margin to zero that
would work and we'll switch this to an
h3 so let's do that
and you see here now within react if you
want to add a style so in react inline
styles are totally fine normally when
you're doing HTML usually it's
recommended that you don't use n line
styles but reacts it's a different story
so within that I know I explained this
almost every episode but there's there's
always new people so I'm probably just
going to explain it again because it
only takes a minute
so within react within this HTML like
stuff called JSX we can go into we can
use JavaScript so if we want to use
JavaScript we just put these curly
brackets and now anything inside this
first set of curly brackets is
JavaScript
so inside there we've put in these other
these other brackets which of course
makes an object in JavaScript so within
that object we put our styles and so in
this case we're gonna use a margin
bottom okay now since we're in
JavaScript we're in a camel case right
if we left that that hyphenated CSS
there like you see here it would think
that that's a minus sign and so we don't
want that so we're gonna use camel case
and just like normal you know normal
JavaScript object we put our colon and
then in single quotes I'm gonna put 0 is
that's what we want our bottom margin to
be the maze will change the color while
we in here so if you want to do another
one we put a comma right because
remember this is an object and this
click color and we need to grab the red
color that we're using for resources so
let's go over here grab this color
oops forgot to put it there we go
alright so that should take care of at
least two of the things we wanted to do
let's check it out
yep there we go so now we have a
different color actually that was all
three right we wanted to change it yeah
we changed it to an h3 yeah that looks a
lot better I like that also I kind of
wonder if we even need this much space I
mean I can work on that maybe I'm
getting a little bit too nitpicky here
but I think we could probably do without
a little space in here maybe like a
horizontal rule here that kind of fades
so no bill last week gave me sent me
some code for doing a really nice
horizontal rule that kind of fades so
maybe I'll grab that and try to use it
here I think that would look really nice
just to differentiate between between
posts also I need to get I need to work
on this part here because obviously
that's not how we want it to look but
okay so it's about 3:30 Eastern Time and
that's when I said that I was going to
stop with the code and do the QA so if
you were just watching for the coding
portion
I guess you you know you don't have to
stick around anymore thank you so much
for watching and I always I'll answer
questions on Twitter in the comments of
stuff so you know feel free to ask me
elsewhere but thanks for watching
otherwise if you have time to stick
around for the question and answer put
your questions in the live chat now and
you know feel if you're in the live chat
- feel free to answer some of the
questions because I certainly benefit
greatly from from your advice and your
experience as well
so let's let's take a look now I'm gonna
scroll up I know I answered a lot of
stuff already but I know it's I've
probably missed a lot as well because
I've been scrolling through the chat
quite quickly so I'm gonna go through
this chat now it's really cool I started
saw a lot of new people in in the chat
today so that's really cool so if you're
new welcome and I really appreciate you
checking things out today
maybe we usually we have like yeah we
have like double the amount of viewers
that usually stick around to this point
so I don't know what happened maybe I
got tweeted or retweeted a lot or
something but maybe it's just a good
topic people were interested in I hope
the topic wasn't too misleading because
I kind of didn't really build an entire
blog I had some of it like made already
but I think I covered a lot of I didn't
cover like how you set up WordPress to
do this but in terms of how to pull in
the data and stuff I covered a decent
amount so sometimes it's I don't want to
make a title too long so it's hard to
explain like exactly what I'm doing
but I don't want to be misleading either
well I'm scrolling through this now I
can see there is quite a bit of of chat
going on about code editors
okay looks like we did have some people
early on asking about reacting what
react is and I don't think I really took
time to explain that so there was
explanation in the live chat so as I'm
scrolling through now I'll explain a
little bit so the question was asked a
long time ago so I'm not sure if the
people who are wondering about it or
even here but react is like it's a
JavaScript framework and it really is a
way to build like single page
applications but not just that you can
build apps with it like mobile apps as
well but it allows you to you mix in
like HTML and CSS and JavaScript and in
a way that you can make these reusable
components that if you do it right or
really almost completely self-contained
and you could use them in different
projects like behind the scenes it's
also really fast at updating the Dom
because it keeps a copy of the DOM and I
think they call it a shadow DOM and then
when a page when things change on a page
JavaScript can do its thing way faster
than you can normally refresh the Dom
and re-render everything so all that
happens in the shadow DOM and then it's
compared to the the real Dom on the
screen Dom being the document object
model that's like all the stuff that
goes into your the web page that you see
on your screen and it only rear Enders
those parts of the dome that have
changed so it's able to do things a lot
faster because things that would
normally require more time to do a
complete dawn-marie render now don't
take as much time so for sites that have
like data changing and updating
automatically it's really nice and I
would assume you could probably see a
performance increase from switching to
react or maybe you know technology that
might be a bit older so there's a lot of
other cool things about react but that's
kind of
some basic stuff at least in my mind
that's what I think of is the main
things that stick out to me for for
reacts and I should say I'm no expert in
react I'm very much learning as I go
along so if you'd like a more complete
answer maybe somebody else in the chat
has given one or you can find maybe you
know the react documentation or some
other YouTube videos that might be
better I know they do a react conference
every year and I'm sure some of those
talks would be able to explain you know
in a lot more depth and in a better way
what react is you're from people who
actually have worked on building react
and Joe says angular seems more
complicated to me than react I started
learning react just two weeks ago and I
already love it more than angular yeah
my um my impression of angular is I
haven't used angular in a couple years I
think I've said this before so I don't
have like an up-to-date opinion on
angular but when I tried it it was hard
for me to learn it was really cool but I
couldn't get anything to work but I
think that was due to my inexperience
with with JavaScript and was setting up
a build environment and it didn't have
anything to do with angular so I'm not
really sure about now angular's come so
far since then so I don't I don't really
have an opinion on the angular versus
react debate
okay Sebastian says Jessie check the
package language babble and Adam it's
for better display for react JSS
actually I think I have that on my
laptop I'll have to double check because
on my laptop I have a different package
for displaying everything and it like
auto format some things for me in
indents so I'll I should have the same
packages on both of my computers for
consistency so thanks for that it
definitely I really do like it on my
laptop
okay I see now that Adi was thought was
talking about the Java console I thought
that so Adi had asked about using dev
tools with Java and I just assumed that
he meant JavaScript but it was really
Java so sorry about that well maybe my
answer to that question it was helpful
for someone but sorry I didn't
understand the question
okay I'm just scrolling through so I for
the the silent silent I'm just I'm just
trying to read through this chat make
sure I don't miss any of your questions
Mohammed asked if this would be up later
yes it will so the video may be just a
minute or two after I've stopped
streaming the video will be available to
watch the recording on free code camps
channel
and I see there's some talk here about
people being being newbies at code and
stuff so I said before someone asked if
if there's anyone else who noob here and
I said yeah I'm a noob and I think I'm
gonna I'm gonna get like a little bit
deep here for a second I honestly think
that when I really stop referring to
myself as a noob I mean if I went in for
a job interview I would you know I would
be very confident and say I knew what I
was doing but like among other
developers and among you all if I ever
stop referring to myself as a noob
that's the point at which I think I
would start stagnating right I would
stop learning
I think it's cool to have that mentality
of a new person because when you're new
starting out there's so much to learn
and you know there's so much to learn
and you're hungry to learn you know
you're willing to work hard and learn
and I always want to keep that I never
want to want to lose that that desire to
learn because I think that's that's
important if you want to continue to be
good and improve yourself so I'm always
gonna answer the question like are you a
noob I'm going to say yes yes I am
because there's always something that I
don't know about there's always some
some piece of web development that I am
a noob at like you can't be good at
everything so it's entirely truthful to
say I am a noob maybe there are certain
things that I've gotten really good at
and I couldn't honestly say that I'm a
noob at but web development is so huge
there's so many different things to
learn I think we're all noobs and one
way or another so when when I say noob I
mean
nothing bad about it at all I mean you
know it's just a noob is just someone
who recognizes that they have a lot to
learn and are gonna learn it
I'd much rather if I was gonna hire a
developer I'd much rather hire someone
who's a noob but really really wants to
learn and work hard versus someone who's
an expert but has just quit learning
I don't know if any of you I'm reading
through the live chat more but I don't
know if anybody has ever seen any of the
Rocky movies so like Sylvester Stallone
did you know the Rocky Balboa movies or
anything but when I think about keeping
that idea of like constantly wanting to
get better the the song from Rocky 3 the
eye of the tiger song always plays in my
head like and that spoiler alert really
quick so you know don't listen to me for
the next couple seconds if you haven't
seen Rocky 3 but rocky ends up losing
because he's lost that desire to keep
getting better and then he ends up
winning because he gets it back right so
so I I always think about that movie
because it's a great like illustration
and film of the concept of always
needing to keep improving yourself and
then the movie the song it's about
staying hungry right you want to stay
hungry for for learning for getting
better
okay cabine us i think that's how you
pronounce it it said create react app is
good for setting up the development
environment pretty quickly so not a
question but that's a it's a really good
really good advice so I want to make
sure I read that out so I use next jazz
for a lot of my projects but you might
not need to use next for your project
like if you don't need server-side
rendering if you want to do your own
setup your own routing you just don't
need it then create react app is great
I'm actually using it on my project for
Udacity so I I'll be I have some
experience with both and it's it's
definitely a really easy way to get
started without having to learn how to
use webpack or anything like that it's
actually cool some people were putting
their their ages in the in the live chat
so I want to read some of them out just
to give give you an idea of the other
people in the chat especially like if
you're watching later and you can't see
the live chat so we have you know
someone's 30 someone's 52 someone's 39
44 someone said that they're 14 I'm 31
so someone's 21 to people of all age
ranges so if you feel like alienated
because of your age there's probably
someone else in this chat that is a
similar age to use so don't don't feel
like you know you have to go it alone
and all honestly like we're all
different ages and different skill
levels and we're all in here in the live
chat talking to each other so it doesn't
really matter what your age or skill
level is you still can you know
contribute and you know join in in this
kind of little community that we have
here
okay let's see
Rohan is saying I think in in response
to talking about doing a lot for the
live chat wrote on Ramona's saying that
there's like a YouTube API for getting a
post in comments that's cool they offed
it I won't have time to check it out
probably for at least another two weeks
but I'm intrigued by the idea of having
something like that okay I could see
when I was doing the dates you all had
some good advice for me for dates so
sorry about that I didn't really check
the live chat because I knew I had done
it before I just needed to find it
Manish asks is that the seti thing it is
the SETI theme for Adam so SETI SETI
thing you someone Vendela said I should
search the code for date I actually did
but I'd use dates so many times it
wasn't really helping me
oh cool Andrew said that he's using
github dark too from when he saw me use
it so that's cool awesome I'm spreading
the github dark theme I can't remember
where I saw that I mean I it's not like
I found it on my own I think I saw
another youtuber using it as well and I
found out what it was from the comments
so I wish I could remember what I saw
because I would give credit but I guess
that's how it works though you know
every everybody gets ideas off of
everyone else and then we're all better
off for it
Patrick said you need some sauce for
that code he was referring to all that
crazy jQuery code that I had going on at
the spaghetti code
hey okay we've had some people are
mentioning moment js2 use with dates so
that's good to know I have to keep that
in mind anybody has to work with dates
check out moment J s I've heard it heard
about it before but I haven't used it so
in this case it was some pretty simple
date things that I was doing but if I
had some more complex things I think it
would definitely be worth it to go with
with something like mum and Jas
I had some other suggestions so
date-date FNS a date - FNS is another
possibility so I might check it out I
mean for right now it's doing what I
wanted to do but I might maybe I'll
check it out and see if I need to do
some more things with dates
cool I had asked Adi Adi said so Addie's
sorry I was reading some Saudis from
Nepal and I had guessed that maybe it's
around 1 a.m. and so I was I was pretty
close oh there's someone from Phoenix
said it's hot in Phoenix
I met it is hot I know I haven't been
the Phoenix myself but I I know a few
people from Phoenix and they've told me
stories about how hot it gets so try to
stay cool over there now okay Alberto
had a great idea I said I didn't really
want the date to stand out too much so
the idea was making some sort of gray
gray color so that's cool maybe I'll
just it's black right now so maybe I'll
just drop down the opacity a little bit
lower I've usually it ends up being a
bit more readable if instead of using
like a hex color for grey you take black
and then drop the opacity to make the
grey I don't know why but visually it
just looks slightly more readable
oh cool all right here's a great tip
this this might be the top tip for the
day I could see this being really
helpful so andrew says when using the
react dev tools if you click on a
component in the react panel you get a
global variable that's dollar sign are
referring to that component and you can
change the state that's really cool to
be able to test things out so thank you
for that for that tip Andrew okay
there's some questions about the the
theme to turn things black so yeah if if
you're referring to the chrome inspector
like for dev tools it's built into dev
tools actually so let me try to find
yeah so if you go into dev tools and
click on you notice little Settings icon
and go down to two settings it has a
theme here so you can choose between the
light and the dark theme so it's already
built in
someone asks about the Udacity course to
see if it covered Redux I just lost it I
want it my my live chat scroll just
jumped ups and I can't I don't know
where I came right stuff that okay
Vendela asks it doesn't cover Redux I'm
pretty sure the react Udacity course
does cover Redux I haven't gotten to
that part yet so I can't say for sure
and I can't can't remember but I think
it does
ok Manish you're still asking about the
the github dark theme oh no so it seems
as if the link to the github dark is
broken
that's thanks I wonder let me bring this
up for a second
yep github
remind me later
okay so I'm gonna I'm gonna copy and
paste this into the into the chat this
is the link that I said I have let me
see if there's a better one this one
should link like directly to some of the
code you can see if that if that link
will work better
they're all and said the chat is
unusually active today you're right it
is it's like it's crazy how much what's
going on I am almost to the bottom
though so probably just a few more
minutes and then I'll have to wrap it up
so I have to get home
ayoh says anyone know why the free code
can't game of life on code pen doesn't
rerender while scrolling I have no idea
I don't know if I've ever looked at that
so maybe someone else can can answer
either the live chat or if you're
watching us later maybe in the comments
or something
okay someone had suggested react
fundamentals so yes like react
fundamentals calm
I lost where the link was but then then
it says they don't use es6 so maybe to
manage to check out modern react Redux
by Stephen gritter so maybe the react
fundamentals was a book and I'm just
mistaken I haven't checked out either
one of those so I can't say for sure but
maybe if you want something that does
use es6 check out the modern react Redux
them says the line between front end and
full stack seems blurry after all
front-end devs do work on server-side
stuff where do you draw a line or it's a
gradual progression towards being a full
stack engineer yeah that's a really good
question I've thought of this before
because you're you're right like I I
know I mean I've even done on some of
the streams some things that are
definitely back-end for me so I was I
was up for like the possibility of
having my title changed and I said for
sure I'm you know my my work is
front-end development work my reasoning
behind it was that I could say maybe
like 10% of what I did was back-end work
and the other 90% was probably front-end
work mixed with design so for me I would
I couldn't justify to myself calling
myself full stack for me if I got to the
point where it was more balanced and I
was more knowledgeable about back-end
things then I would be more comfortable
saying full stack but I think you're
right the line is definitely blurry I
mean and where do you draw a line if you
did 25% back-end and 70% front-end you
know is that enough does it have to be
closer to 5050 like and I mean everybody
does different things maybe one week I
think there there are weeks were all go
entire week where I'm basically all
going back end stuff the almost the
whole week and then there are other
times where I'll go like a month doing
almost nothing with the back end so it
is a weird line I would say honestly
like whatever whatever job you can get
that's what you end up being but
whatever title they give you because it
really is such a kind of a blurry a
blurry line nowadays all right andrew
has two questions all wrote grow up
before I move on Roland said everyone is
full-stack doesn't matter if you like it
or not yeah there's definitely some
truth in that comment like sometimes you
just have to do everything to get a
project done so Andrea two questions
first question how how you holding XJS
for async calls okay so I'm not I think
this is what you're talking about are
you talking about like when I make the
API calls up here if so this get initial
props is like if you put stuff in here
this will render server side as well I'm
not sure if this is what you're asking
about or not but I think so and that's
that is like a built-in thing into next
and there's some documentation on it and
their github repo as to how it works out
I don't know exactly how it works
the next question is did you encounter
problems using jQuery and react and
Sebastian already answered yes to that
one so yeah it's true I did have
problems actually I did a stream where I
went through some of the problems with
with react and jQuery so you can check
out that stream if you want a longer
explanation but basically yeah the
problems found a lot of the problems
come from two things one when you change
the dawn
with jQuery reacts doesn't know about it
so you know normally you want to change
things in state you know with set state
and then react knows and can rerender if
you start changing things in the Dom
with jQuery it messes up reacts picture
of what the Dom is you know that shadow
Dom so you don't want to do that the
other thing that gets messed up is a lot
of the things that you do with jQuery
you put inside your document already
function well when you're using
client-side routing inside react and
when you're rerender in components with
react some of those triggers that you
would normally have trigger inside the
document already function don't work so
I had to find other ways to call those
those things to initialize some of those
those features that I was using that the
use jQuery so a lot of times I could
just do it in inside the component did
mount function so it's like that that's
a short answer I did a whole stream on
how I got around it but it was actually
I was able to get pretty much everything
working I think that I I wanted to get
working but if I had the time I'd like
to go in and change everything over so
that I'm not using jQuery at all but for
now I'm still using some jQuery
andrew says it might work their deaths
with ten or more years of experiences
still don't know all the tricks of death
yeah definitely it's like you know you
can't ever get to the end of it it's
just changing so fast there's new stuff
all the time
packy says I'm a newbie and I gave three
interviews made it to the final round
but every time I find new things to
learn from an interview [ __ ] says though
not not made it through the HR round so
cool that's I'm glad that's really good
that you're able to learn things from
your interview sometimes people get
really down about interviews where they
didn't get the job like it's a waste but
it's definitely not a waste the
experience you get is is really good
them says you Adrian that's that's from
the movie from the Rocky movie I was
talking about earlier so so vim knows
M's watched it [ __ ] says how to address
interview frustration I'm really
frustrated I Pike says I'm 25 I started
last year I don't know with the
interview I mean there's been times when
I've been looking for jobs and trying to
get you know do interviews and sending
out you know a lot of resumes and things
and it is really hard to get down you
know to get through you get down on
yourself a lot so I mean for me this is
going to be really kind of general
advice but the toughest thing for me was
just like you get you get depressed
because you can't find a job and then
when you're depressed you don't want to
do anything so you you stop looking
since I get downward spiral where you
know you're you don't want to do
anything anymore you don't want to send
out resumes or go on interviews you're
still so down and then it makes it your
chances of getting a job even worse so
for the most important thing to me is
breaking that downward spiral making
sure you don't get into it and for that
I think things unrelated to even coding
or good so like exercise
you know doing things that you like
hobbies and things just to get your mind
out of that negative cycle is good and
then in terms of coding stuff like work
on side projects that you like to keep
up that sense of accomplishment you know
contribute to open source projects like
every time your pull request gets
accepted you'll feel good and like
that'll just give you that little lift I
think that'll keep you out of you know
getting so down on yourself and being
depressed and it'll give you a sense of
accomplishment so it'll help you going
into the interviews because you can go
in with confidence with real confidence
you know because you have these little
successes so that would be my advice I'm
sure you know others in the chat and
others watching this later on we'll
probably have some you know even better
advice as well but for me that's always
just a struggle for me is you know
keeping enough confidence just to keep
going and not get into that just
sluggishness of you know not wanting to
do anything because you get too down on
yourself
Rowan says when is it not hot in Phoenix
so earlier I think it was I think Monica
mentioned that it was really really hot
in Phoenix so Rowan that's probably I
think it is always hot in Phoenix I'm
like there may be times where it's
slightly cooler but it's still probably
hotter in Phoenix all the time than it
is you know where I'm from in Ohio
yeah Rowan said yeah it is after four
well I got carried away okay so I'm
gonna wrap it up now because I have to
go and take my son to karate so there's
a few more questions in there sorry I
didn't get to it so if you're still
listening and you're like one of the
people that have a couple question at
the bottom so like umberto is writing
something and oh okay Kevin did say I
will read this out react Saddam is
called virtual Dom shadow Dom as part of
web components thank you so much I can I
can't ever keep it straight I always mix
them up so I apologize before I was
calling reacts virtual Dom a shadow DOM
and it's not that's something different
so the virtual Dom is what react halves
so thank you so much for that correction
so sorry if I messed up anyone's
understanding of this so anyway I do
really have to go now I'm sorry I didn't
get to all the questions Sebastian I see
your question put it in the comments or
message me on Twitter or something so I
can get back to you on that but anyway
thank you so much for watching and I'll
be back tomorrow and have a great day